[Music]
Team USA is looking to sweep immense
freeski after fight competition at the
Winter Olympics the event made its
Olympic debut at the 2014 games in sochi
qualifying rounds for this year begin
tonight Colorado native Torrey Nader
with a very cool name turin later
Wallace hopes to earn a spot on the
podium he is one of the most decorated
freestyle skiers in the world Don Dahler
shows us how he overcame
life-threatening obstacles on his
journey to this year's Olympics Don good
morning good morning
time and again 22 year old tornado
Wallace has defied the odds on the
halfpipe but it's not this
life-and-death sport that has dealt him
his biggest challenge two years ago a
mysterious illness brought him to the
brink of death here Wallace fought his
way back and now he is chasing
Redemption the freedom and just the
expression of yourself that you have
when you're essentially just kind of
creating your own path throughout the
mountain it's just that feeling of
accomplishment when you've landed the
perfect run I mean there's really
nothing like it and I mean whether it's
just tricks or just catch an air off of
a little cliff tornador wallace knows
how to catch air and float in control as
he flies off a 22 foot high wall his
death-defying tricks on the halfpipe
have helped make him one of the most
decorated freestyle skiers in the world
during his first run at Olympic glory
and Sochi the ADA Wallace's path the
gold seemed inevitable but days before
the games his mother was diagnosed with
cancer and following an accident during
a routine treatment he suffered a
collapsed lung the ADA Wallis finished a
disappointing 26th place your most
life-threatening moment didn't happen on
a mountain it happened because of a tiny
little microbe
but you almost were gone you know
it's uh often a hard time to think about
whilst I do a dangerous sport that
people have lost their life competing in
my biggest life-threatening event was an
infection to my internal organs and I
was on full life-support and you know
really was on the brink of death in 2015
yater Wallace developed a rare infection
in his liver and gall bladder that put
him in a 10-day medically induced coma
did you know at the time you were that
close so I was in and out of a few
doctors and out of the ER a few times
essentially told me I had a flu-like
virus and you know here's some Tamiflu
and things just got worse and worse from
there I woke up like 10 days later so I
mean at the time I really didn't realize
the extent of the situation I was just
in dire pain and had never been so sick
in my life his father's absence added to
the pain he was in prison for defrauding
clients and you know it's really
frustrating for him more so than me when
your son is you know on stuff bed and
might not make it and you can't do
anything the mere act of breathing was a
challenge but yater wall is soon
recovered and took fate into his own
hands it was one of the scarier moments
in my entire life and it was a fluke and
there's nothing I could have done to
prevent what happened to me happening
and I mean ultimately I just really have
to take the good from such a horrible
event and use it as motivation to to
come back and come back he did just two
months after his near-death scare he won
the gold medal at the X Games in Oslo
Norway now with a renewed sense of
purpose
he hopes to persevere one more time the
Olympics is just such a cool opportunity
everything is is personal everything's
for you in a somewhat selfish way so
it's kind of that opportunity to go to
this tournament of the countries and
kind of represent something bigger than
yourself
yan'er Wallace will soon get another
chance to do just that his mother who is
now cancer-free will be in South Korea
rooting for him alongside his sister and
his father oh I like everything about
him he is a great kid he's been
considered one of the best in the world
since he was 14 years old so he grew up
skiing and it's like walking for him
what's beautiful to watch I'll tell you
it's not like when he said the Olympics
is personal yeah you and you and you
he's not afraid of anything now as
clearly and great he has his family
around done